[Applause]
all right everybody we got such a good
show tonight a lot of fun stuff planned
uh we've been doing uh something that i
think has been very edifying for
everybody
uh we've been shining uh recently a bit
of a spotlight not on me but on my staff
i have a lot of talented people that
work for me at the show
uh these are terrific people they
contribute a lot to the show over the
last 14 years
and we've learned a lot today i want to
do it again
i want to shine a light on a very
talented man
he's the director of special effects
he's the person that provides all the
cool special effects that we do here
on our talk show and uh his name is john
greenfield and he's done a lot of work
for us
the other day uh this is actually a
little while ago right because i still
had the beard
i met with him in the special effects
lab here in 30 rock
i spent a little time with him it was
pretty fascinating take a look
i'm standing here with john greenfield
john your title is
special effects director special effects
director
uh our show uh likes occasionally do
some
special effects and you're the guy we go
to a lot of successes
sometimes an occasional blooper misfire
yeah would you say that i'm calm and
kind in those moments
absolutely you shook your head no when
you said yes
you realize that you said absolutely
your signal i think got out to everyone
watching
nicely done john you're going to do a
little demonstration for us now tell us
what we're going to do
we're going to take an object normally
found on your desk then
the famous mug yes and you're gonna do
what to it i'm just gonna blow it up
blow it up i might wear protective
glasses i hope it's okay i've taken the
liberty of borrowing your look
you always wear yellow glasses why gives
me a fresh outlook when i come into the
office
sure the whole world looks like it's
been doused in urine
should i give you countdown on three
does that mean we start on three and go
to one
does it mean we start on one and go to
three and is it on three or is it after
three
uh it's on three and start at one okay
one two hold it
so it's on three it's on three okay
is it weird to start on one should we
start on zero perhaps yes
okay zero one
two now right um that's gonna be on
three and then the explosion do you
wanna do it after three
three how about one two i think it's
more dramatic to go one
two i'm this this is the way i am i'm
one of those kind of guys i'm a guy
that's like
one two because three the suspense is
really like nah
and then after three it happens and then
where four would be
the explosion that way you get to hear
three gotcha cool
let's go and we let's lose zero
one two
three
not bad that was pretty good and there
was a cracking sound
paint held it together this stuff i'm
breathing
is that toxic uh slightly yeah that's
great
is it really toxic well there's some
metal fragments in there
we're breathing metal fragments yeah
what the
what is that we have a nice overhead
exhaust system this is the exhaust
system that's supposed to save my life
right now look at that right there
the smoke is actually coming out of it
john what you got there
cam flash unit you said it very quickly
hand flash
flash unit hold your hand up then
whoa i have a criticism of the way you
did it you just went oh
you know what i mean you know what i
mean you have to probably uh
put a little showmanship into it to
really sell it right right how dare you
meddle with me
you're me immortal and i a
[Laughter]
afterwards there's a little god of a
feeling here i probably oversold it
with my acting you know what i mean you
expected more
i'm a guy who's bragging about how he's
a god and then
is this power anything there's a little
whoa
that's uh the trouser wiggler
trouser wiggler yes you put that in your
pants
you put this in your pants oh and it
makes it look like
something's going on yeah it's radio
controlled
yeah i've heard about these new models
that are radio controlled
the one my dad had was gas powered
okay john you're now ready to uh make a
second
attempt exploding the eisenhower yes uh
what are you going for this time that
wasn't achieved the first time complete
destruction
you want the whole mug to fly apart
that's what i intended yes
one two three
four
my favorite thing to do is it's one of
those things you put in the key and you
turn it and then what do i push
as you bring these up to the arm
position they will fire
wow okay can i do this is that all right
yeah yeah
all right let's do this uh little let's
have some theatrics to this okay okay
the movie's called uh uh tender is
midnight
and uh your character's name is lorraine
lorraine lorraine yes an attractive
waitress and action sir the situation's
great
just use your normal voice all right
let's try it again all right and
uh you you're a woman that's been turned
into a man
and action sir the situation is critical
the weapon must be fired i need the
key i'll try it again tender's midnight
uh take two action
sir we're under attack the weapon must
be fired if you hold the key up
i can see it take three uh scene where
lorraine enters
a man and action sir the situation is
critical the weapon must be fired damn
it i don't have a key
yes it's in god's hands now
what you got john crying glasses
crying glasses and what do they do you
put these on
put them on uh-huh and it simulates that
i actually
have emotions
[Laughter]
oh god why
this time let's do it on three got it
okay so where three would be but i won't
say three
or do you want me to say three but it's
still on three okay
one two
[Applause]
three
all right let's get them out here ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
little mutts don't you think all right
we'll take a break when we come back uh
sean thayer is here with this crazy
military robot stick around